okay so here we are eating your feed the
show where people like me get challenged
to try and recreate viral food recipes
my friend Adam is challenging me today
to make Japanese fluffy pancakes not a
lot of steps but it's going to require
some skill
it's the perfect level for my level of
cooking which is amateur at best but I'm
optimistic hand mixer on the egg whites
getting it to the nice stiff fluff there
okay so now they're adding the pancake
mix into the three and a half inch molds
so they put the lid on it rises 10
minutes now the flip is going to be very
difficult that is pancake perfection
right there I love pancakes straight up
so to help me today is our food expert
3a okay thank you for coming are you
making today fluffy Japanese pancakes
okay yeah have you eaten Japanese okay
pigeon no so egg whites it's the most
important part of this fluffy pancake if
you over mix it become very crumbly it's
not that difficult a sketch or anything
you like thank you bye bye
okay in here we have our molds imagine
that I mean everything like living in
loony-tune land where tanks are this
tall and fluffy so right now we're going
to take two egg yolks
quarter cup of sugar the people in other
countries get stressed out when they
watch us cooking just because I wish we
were saying it in the metric system it's
about time we switch huh half cup of
milk every last drop 3/4 cup of pancake
mix looks like 3/4 what you think guys
at home what's going in all right
whisking together you have that now
we're going to add our four egg whites
here's two okay that's three all right
for plugging our hand mixer okay we're
in know that is a great question mm I've
never hand mixed just not gonna
overthink it just gonna go for it
so that's what that button does okay
things are in some may just need to be
unlocked no okay we know what that
button does in hmmm daddy's got a beat
it by hand I mean that's impossible
right I don't want to do that at all
okay
new mixer okay what the f
I think we just have a bad power source
all right so we have a bad plug let's go
to the noise we're going all the way in
six by the way the volume is increasing
I'd say we're tripled maybe quadruple
the original volume close not Stan its
same the peak is staying okay let's see
if the tasty video see how peak that
that good no yeah this is it I think I
might have overdone it we're gonna get
in there but just slightly we want these
two mixed together but we don't want to
lose the whip I think it's too crumbly
maybe not though it's not that far off
let's go for it let's get our heat going
we're gonna put this on the lowest heat
one all right both are in we greased up
our moulds you know three quarters of
the way in okay let's cover it okay
pulling off trying to separate Jesus
disaster sorry folks
yeah okay well this is a failure it's a
miserable failure my god what is
happening here Patrick I don't think the
flame was high enough although it rose
so what the hell is that mean I don't
know it smells fantastic though so first
attempt didn't work what do we learn
flame will be a little bit higher
maybe try them one at a time I don't
know second attempts we're gonna use
what was left in the batter put the lid
on I was using a fish spatula last time
because that's what they used in the
video but now I'm gonna use this one
because I can probably hook it in a lot
better bubbling up at the top looking
very similar to what we were doing
before it's making all types of cracking
noises stop doing that if I was someone
else if I was really be doing what you
need to do but for me two minutes we're
getting high look how high that is I've
never cooked a pancake on one side for
ten minutes all right it smells
delicious
[Music]
well you burnt the bottom of that one we
knew that so we need to adjust the heat
can't figure out a better way to flip it
throw these tongs aren't it these knees
can't do it i greased up then sigh do I
need to grease it win one oh yeah that
pancake II clogged your windpipe this is
fluffy they weren't lying is everything
you wanted on the inside definitely more
edgy but and try it it's pretty good
yeah with sheriff butter the whole thing
uh-oh how's it going what is the best
way to flip it I think they say it's not
a good one not too good let me get done
good one okay dad tongs these aren't
tasty tongs that was the problem you
know I'm ready to sell out so hard but
no one will give me a shot at selling
out I would sell out for a surprisingly
low amount 2019 I'm gonna be a micro
influence there why did I mean I want to
sell out okay because I was saying how
these aren't any good uh-huh and I would
love to do an advertisement for a really
good brand Oh like tasty yes
only at Walmart you see how good she is
I will do that
oh god that was so easy oh you can feel
the silicon
oh my all right well that answers that
I'm gonna mix them up
[Applause]
yeah that's stiff go okay that looks
decent
let's grease the molds okay that looks
about three quarters cover it up
ten minutes eight minutes we're seeing
some bubbling on top how do you normally
talk a little powdered sugar is
fantastic five minutes
oh my spatula boy it's hitting the top
all right - it off
oh it's guys all right everyone relax
okay get it low get it low god I hate
the way this is shaking I hate the way
the sticking yeah that looks good
that Brown really was right about the
temperature it overflowed like crazy my
goodness Oh put this back on can't get
ahead of yourself with cooking that I
mean how many times we have to
well the tongs worked so that's good one
minute oh my god
room with square plates where the thing
the embarrassing to have been you're
home now yeah yeah oh my god do we think
I mean it's brown it's not light brown
but it's brown Oh
[Music]
all right so the presentation of this
plate not great so now that I've gotten
this far I'm going to try and make two
at the same time and see if I can stack
them up and then I'll have some friends
over to try it up so last attempts we're
going to try and make two and instead of
using vegetable oil to grease up the
molds we're going to use spray canola
oil hopefully they'll make it slide out
a little bit better okay - got it better
here okay just a little bit more ten
minutes four minutes
yeah it's rising two minutes matter of
seconds
oh man look how much they've risen to 49
flippin come on man you could do it you
could do it bro oh yeah bro oh yeah hell
yeah why not me one two
23 skidoo here we go oh my god a laptop
just fell then everything's crazy right
now we're flipping anyways mate oh god
why God no all right screw it this is
the last one all right here we go mother
who cares honestly who cares whatever
foot it back on I'll cut around it this
sucks
this really sucks cooking is fun right
guys Adam is trying to cheer me up
behind the camera
maybe these are salvageable who knows
we'll see how my mood is in four minutes
so let's check back in then alright
let's take them out they look way better
you know my kids are getting these and
I'm liking them that's how this goes in
my house you want to cry about it well
guess it's not even fluffy Japanese
pancakes I'm gonna try and cut these out
using a method that Adam came up with by
pushing down hopefully that eliminates
everything there and then I can just
flick it up oh oh oh my god Adam you
little whiz kid you freakin figured it
out okay there's one whoa
and all the sins are forgiven of that
terrible flip - oh right oh my god guys
breakfast is served
Wow comment below what you think cuz to
me not bad let's cut the butter now
that's just the bun oh no we'll flip it
over yep we'll flip it over hell yeah
dude we'll flip it over here it is guys
[Applause]
Wow that's that's very jiggly yeah man
that's not it I'm not gonna slap it you
slap it oh wow it's bottles dirty yeah
how many times did you try this is the
fourth time oh yeah oh yeah right
they're like no no wow look like a kink
whoa just jumping in again they're
getting there anna has anyone had a
restaurant version of this before me how
does this compare I think yeah you know
that right Wow okay thank you okay
you're gonna whip this out and like the
weekends now I know yeah I'm into it
I say the flip was the most challenging
part I'm sure there's like an algorithm
to figuring out the right speed versus
velocity of rotation etc etc give me
10,000 hours check back in will see
where I'm at well I'm proud of myself
it's been another episode of eating your
feed I'm proud of you too hey thanks
[Music]
oh yes